what's happening reject nation its Greg
outta here and it's John over here so
we're going to cover the top movie news
of the week and of course with the
people over at patreon you'll get a few
more extra stories that will be covering
over there exclusively but today we'll
be going into the movie news of the week
from around July 7th to July 14th we got
about five stories here let's hop right
into it all right so our top story
rumor has it that Quintin Tarantino's
next feature film had to be supposed to
retire after a couple more films which I
don't think you'll actually fully commit
to just some very program from parent
I'm not gonna happen I did one of them
so everything whatever I'm really any
any creative who retires just needs a
break yeah that's basically what I'm
gathering from this I supposedly his
next story his next movie that he's
developing is quite an interesting
choice yeah he might do a Charles Manson
movie and he's reportedly been in talks
to you know reports come from deadlines
that he is prepping to do a Charles
Manson biopic story
they'll probably sent her a little bit
more around the sounds like the trials
and the investigation because he's said
that he's been courting Brad Pitt to
play the detective who's the lead on the
case
Jennifer's a girl possibly for the share
and taint role no no the Charles Mann
for the story
Charles Manson had a cult and then be if
its followers murder Sharon Tate and
she's pregnant Cameron yeah they busted
into this party at Lancome and Polanski
houses yeah and murder her for other
people stabbed them all to death
multiple times as violence or a tween
documentaries on it horrific tale and I
would be interested in seeing this one
because the few mentioned adaptations of
scene do take place you know leading up
to the Sharon Tate murder and about the
murder but I don't I'm not familiar with
any adaptations maybe there's a few or
something out there that covers the
actual trial itself because when I watch
documentaries of
I do find myself really fascinated by
the trial situation because because
Charles Manson didn't himself commit any
of these these murders maybe he killed
people but he wasn't convicted of
actually murdering anybody just enticing
a lot of other peanuts man dudes nuts
and watch them going you to look up some
Charles Manson interviews may have some
food in the same yeah and he's a strange
guy but anyway with this story the
reason why it's interesting to me is
because tension has never done a biopic
and I know like when he did glorious
bastards people were wondering like
what's this going to be like and if you
watch it you'll see it's a major piece
of historical fiction and yeah there
there are people notable people but none
of them are the central character yeah
see I think that'll definitely be
interesting to see how how he approaches
adapting a more real life story telling
more real people memories because you
know there's always going to be some
reality bending I feel like that comes
jarrandi know and that era I know he has
a specific fascination with if you look
at his movies a lot of times his films
will pay homage to that kind of style
from that era so I'm wondering how he
would how he would shoot this film and
hearing that you know they want to do
some courtroom trial stuff and also the
detective area of it I'm wondering any
and Tarantino is also known to sort of
play with how he moves around time to
time lasted and such you know you can go
from the this is in the past than the
future like he hops around he watched
Pulp Fiction you know you'll see how he
messes with time Reservoir Dogs as well
so it doesn't sound like it would just
be a this one super linear film I'm very
curious and I feel like courtroom drama
surprisingly when I heard about this
story I thought courtroom drama
I feel like Tarantino corrections killed
a courtroom dialogue yeah I feel like
the more I hear about this project the
more interesting it becomes to me
because it seems reasonably clear that
he's not just trying to make something
ghoulish inand you know horrible yeah
you know I feel like especially knowing
the way Tarantino assembles a movie and
how broad and strange this whole story
is there's a lot for him to play around
Brown and I feel like he's a guy who
does a lot of research and we'll do
we'll really dredge up some interesting
thing I feel like this would be his most
different film I mean I know the Manson
story has been done several times before
but you can't really go to Tarantino II
on this one
yeah child meds on the stand free spring
and he's grabbing damn [ __ ] narrator
Harry Charles mance and then you know
it's like he's known for Popey
exploitive violence and I'm like I don't
think that kind of fun violence were
worth well and it's Harold Vinson biopic
you can't really have fun with the
violence here yeah I'm I'm very curious
about that yeah especially because you
know this is a very heavy story yeah
it's a very touchy subject handled Eshel
air you know yeah because I'm thinking
like well this this be Tarantino asket
all really yeah he's been it like it's
interesting to watch his career unfold
because I do think like even though all
of his movies maintain a certain level
of Pulp in a certain level of Tarantino
NIST's the older he's gotten and the
later films seem to be pushing and a bit
more of a not restrained but maybe I
would call it mature direction yeah you
know and you know that I hope that this
actually sees him maybe relying less on
you know pulp and violence and more on
you know his skills as a writer and a
dialog guy way ya gotta be tons of like
if you go back to like its first three
films it you know reservoir Pulp Fiction
and Jackie Brown and all three of those
had some violence in it but they're not
heavy on on gore and violence as opposed
to like Kill Bill or hateful eight or
Django or inglorious like his last few
films are a lot heavier on violence and
the thing about it when you hear about
the Charles Manson and this murder of
Sharon Tate not everything if anyone's
another but it's like
there is a real grizzly thing that yeah
very violent in a way that can't be fun
yeah so I don't know maybe it sounds to
me like maybe he was really did the
People vs OJ and want to make kind of a
story like that maybe I know a few guys
have been trying to do stories like this
because there was a while ago there was
an announcement that a Bret Easton Ellis
and Rob Zombie we're going to do some
kind of series about the investigation
or whatever Rob Zombie won be nasty I
feel like because the Rob Zombie even
though his films are like categorized a
lot as horror films they can feel like
have this weird sense of realism where
the violence just isn't fun but hey
everything is part of what I appreciate
because I feel like Rob Zombie could do
true crime you know I feel like it would
be uncomfortable but I feel like he
would translate it pretty well on that
one or two that would put a set of
parameters around him so not everyone is
a is is you know swearing and speaking
in yeah I totally agree with that
but as far as Tarantino yeah hopefully I
mean I you hear you say Tarantino is
making a film I'm excited this is yajna
bill he's easily the most consistent
director around today next to Martin
Scorsese in my opinion
we'll see who hate me on that job but
Tarantino is one of those directors and
writers that if I hear you doing
something I'm most likely going to check
it out opening weekend and we'll
probably end up really enjoying the hell
out of the phone well the only other
thing too about this that makes me
curious is the earliest word I heard on
this movie was that he was researching
music from the 70s yeah music business
and like things like that and so a
Manson was very into music yeah and he
you could hip songs are on iTunes which
is weird yeah but uh so yeah I also
wonder how that's going to play it you
know maybe he saw a vinyl and OJ
back-to-back it was like I know what to
disconnect his baby driver Adam all
right guys so with war of the plates
coming out this weekend why not talk
about this story
the Batman direct
Matt Reeves yeah he on his brother he's
I've never thought it was obvious he
ain't ever thought it up I'm happy very
pleased he is not using Ben Affleck
script for the Batman just another
reason to add on to Ben Affleck the
press reason another reason for Ben
Affleck to be depressed and I feel I do
kind of feel for him in this situation
because it was like oh he's coming into
everything and now rectum right the
Bevins you'd be the coolest was epic
Batman projects ever heard and now is
you need a good which is good which
would you know at least with DC just
needing to focus up and make sure
everything's on point yeah focus on just
being Bruce yeah you know there's pros
and cons that I feel towards this story
again I mean obviously the cons are it's
a bummer because I know Ben Affleck was
already working his ass off on the
script going on jimmy kimmel telling
people the chill out resumes is not
bothering him about it when he said like
I was interested to see what his Batman
script yeah because he's a different
kind of a writer and he's not just a
great director he's also a fantastic
writer as well so I was I was excited
just for his script alone because you
know when the big ordeal when they found
out all he's not actually going to
direct it but he they still will use his
script that was like the saving grace
filmmakers side of Ben Affleck was well
at least they're still he's still
involved with the script and they're
going to be using that screenplay and
now Matt Reeves is saying they want to
start completely from scratch which kind
of raises another concern Joe mingle
Anna men jello grand Jill and Angelo he
was he's supposed to be a Deathstroke
yeah destro right knows Deadshot there's
that's right yeah it's supposed to be
Deathstroke and they tease like footage
that been a Polly put up on an Instagram
really yeah they had like this great
footage that they were showing that
people got really excited for no people
assume that it might be footage he might
they might ease and justice Lee because
Justice League sounds like it's just
going to be another movie that's setting
up a bunch of other movies yeah
although standalone movies are setting
up the crossover movies and all the
crossover movies
sending up a sandal and that that is one
the more we look at this the more
strange that decision plays to me out
like I don't know half these two yeah I
am going to be distracted by Batman and
Wonder Woman so so am I thinking well
they're going to do a completely
different strippers I mean Deathstroke
is going to be the villain is he going
to be the guy or are they going to have
to you know write him out now and all
that excitement goes out the window or
will will he be able to renegotiate for
a different character or something
because that's just kind of a bond feel
sorry for the actor right there yeah but
on the flip side
I'm thinking it's matt reeves you know
and if Matt Reeves wants to use a new
script he should because he's the
director and at the end of the day it's
a director's medium whatever the film is
and if matarese if we want Matt Reeves
to give us the same level of quality
filmmaking he made for the last planet
of the apes films he has to work from
what he really wants to do he has to
work from that he can't just go in okay
here's a script I'm going to adapt this
he has to go in a fully-fledged the
original concept that he feels
passionate about in order to give us the
film that will be great because the only
way this phone's going to be great is if
Matt Reeves is making the movie he
actually wants to make that's pretty
much what he said when he I believe he
commented on this too and basically said
like yeah I told WB I was just like if I
do this I I would like I would feel the
most comfortable and the most equipped
to give the best movie possible with
material I'm familiar with with my own
script at least you know and it seems
like they're going to use are they going
to use any of this stuff from Ben
Affleck script or they added I were on
that it sounds like they're just
starting again okay and I mean he
basically said like that's just what I
told WB and then they were like yeah
okay yeah we'll take that so and he's
proven himself capable over time you
know I his filmography is pretty solid
and he's shown us that he can do
blockbusters that are more than just
blood or emotional yeah and we need that
and we also need that especially for DC
you know like they're off to a good
start with Wonder Woman finally hitting
a stride like that and it's you know
it's capable and totally and the other
thing about the matarese story was he
was he was also talking about doing
he has kind of a trilogy in mind which
sounds cool I mean why not if you're
gonna if Christopher Nolan at his
trilogy one I wouldn't be surprised by
directors like I want to do my Batman
trilogy now but here's where the but
comes like big bond but if if Matt
Reeves is setting out on that path I can
get a little concerned because you know
when he did dawn of the Planet of the
Apes even we signed on for that movie
he wasn't signing offer for two
installments he was signed on for that
movie and so he put his best into that
one project didn't worry about another
installment he's just going to make the
best film he could possibly make and if
they're in early negotiations for him to
do a trilogy he might be able to pull it
off some people pull off amazing
trilogies um I would however just like
him to focus on this one great Batman
movie yeah most definitely I mean he
seems like a resourceful dude Matt and I
got to imagine if you're imagining a
Batman trilogy I'm sure that he's got
ideas but yeah I'm I feel good right now
with DC at all just one at a time in the
way to go you know make sure that this
is because that's that is an inherent
problem with franchise building is that
stories get stunted by having to
continue forever
yeah and so yeah I definitely hope that
they just focus up on this that no one
talked about that was the reason why no
one took breaks with his Batman films he
talked about that saying how he doesn't
like to preserve or hold on or wait for
something for a future installment he
tries to do the best he can give it his
all for the one use as many of the ideas
as possible that'll work fluidly in this
one story instead of going you know
let's not put this in here to save it
for a feature install yeah yeah well and
taking time between allows you to
reflect on it yeah you know do something
else get some new inspiration and come
back and go okay now how can I continue
yeah and I don't I don't want the
director like Matt Reeves either to sign
up for a trilogy and have to spend the
next ten years working on its religious
you know yeah totally
I'm definitely with it yeah you know and
that's the tricky oh I think part of the
trickiest thing about these kinds of
movies is that there's a constant demand
and it can lock a filmmaker up for ages
yeah yeah and then you know rushing
through them or doing so many in tandem
you know kind of waters down the
storytelling sometimes it's nice to miss
a character for a little while before
they come back
no no I'm waiting for the Netflix model
where they make like seven movies and
release them all on the same you can
just like marathon like a whole oh
decade's worth of franchise one day
all right reject nation that's it for
today's movie news the top stories of
the week we got you know of course on
our patreon you can go to our patreon
and we have more stories that we cover
over there a bunch of other fun stuff as
well expended underrated edition of the
news patreon.com plus L'Oreal regex but
as always subscribe to the real rejects
if you're new and click that
notification bell pay for your meme or
if you're subscribed it already and you
just have a quick they click it click it
dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
house calm take care pipes